hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for
GameSpot here on the frontline at San
Diego comic-con 2014 I met a very cool
event with gas gas how are you doing
yeah great thank you this is a
celebration of Batman's 75th anniversary
it's the Cape Carl creates exhibit
exhibition it's basically an art exhibit
we've taken the Batman Arkham Knight bat
suit and we've given it to a load of
artists creative celebrities and they've
just done their own thing to create
whatever it is they wanted to do their
own version of the most iconic suit in
crime-fighting so we've seen the guys
from Scribblenauts they've created their
own cape with loads of classic DC
characters on we've got a Los Angeles
tagging version over here we've got one
that kind of looks like an ice-cream
with a waffle cone it's just a
celebration of Batman a celebration of
art and and what a what better way to do
the 75th anniversary in style well I
think you know Batman suit is the most
iconic suit in crime-fighting right the
bat suit is when Bruce Wayne puts that
on he becomes the Batman and so when the
way that we approach our game design is
always to make the player feel like
Batman so I guess you could say in a
sense that our our game is the bat suit
for for people who pick up the who pick
up the controller great well in terms of
Batman Arkham Knight Lincoln our viewers
look for that game and what special
things should they really be be
expecting and being excited for for the
game well one of the cool things about
the bats that we've designed is that it
interfaces really well with the
Batmobile and the battery is the big
thing that we really wanted and finally
wanted to bring to the Arkham series so
it's totally drivable it's totally
awesome
and when gamers get a chance to play it
in 2015 they're gonna they're gonna see
why yeah I did get a chance at e3 to see
that Batmobile and the the cool tactical
movement that you got going on there is
really exciting so I can't wait to check
that out I'm sure you at home can't wait
to check it out as well let me know what
you're most excited for for Batman
Arkham Knight by tweeting at me at Anna
Prosser
you